art I don't want to alarm you Jacob is
talking about isekai again
in the beginning there was darkness and
then God said boom let there be light so
he created Sword Art Online this
happened in the prehistoric era of 2012.
by now we all know the origin story of
the modern isekai genre and how it's
come to saturate the anime Market it's
been almost a decade a decade since the
initial isakai boom so you think after
all this time audiences would finally
start to get bored and yet somehow we
don't seem to be getting less we seem to
be getting more so that begs the
question if you're not watching isakai
and you're not watching isekai and
you're not watching isekai then who's
watching all the Issa guy it's me I
watched a lot of visakai last year and I
know I've played my part in giving the
genre the image that it has but I
honestly think that the genre might be
on the path to a brighter future
don't mind me just taking my daily dose
of copium I think 2021 was one of the
strongest years for isakai I feel like
possibly the history of isekai and like
I thought we all agreed that the genre
was already stale like five years ago so
today I thought I'd break down just
what's going on with isakai today why I
think it's here to stay and the number
one thing I still absolutely hate about
the genre spoiler alert it's not what
you think it is yeah that was enough
clickbait in that intro right but before
we get to that a quick word from our
sponsor hey there do you like awesome
stuff of course you do you watch isakai
every one of us needs more awesome stuff
well thankfully today's episode is
sponsored by bespoke post bespoke post
is a monthly membership club delivering
awesome boxes of top shelf good from
under the radar Brands that's free to
join they do a bunch of different boxes
from outdoor gear barware kitchen goods
clothing and so many other cool stuff if
you're looking for a new casual hobby or
just something new to dip your toes into
then this is the perfect service for you
like just look at the stuff they sent me
from the terror box I got an absolute
Giga Chad knife yeah
I can't wait to use this next time we go
camping or outdoors from their Smoke Box
we got the smoked cocktail infusion kit
and I already know I'm gonna have a lot
of fun making cocktails with these but
my absolute favorite thing they've sent
me this month is this Weekender bag
which is just the perfect casual bag to
pack up all your essential items you
need for a weekend trip which is no joke
actually perfect for me because I'm
literally about to go on a trip so I'm
going to be using this almost
immediately it really couldn't have come
at a bad time and yeah I'm already
packed and ready to go every box has
around 70 in retail value but only costs
49 and the best thing is everything is
customizable you can take a quiz to
choose the type of products that would
suit you and every month you'll get a
preview of The Box and if you don't like
what you see you can just swap it for a
different box or just skip the month
entirely free of charge yes you only pay
for what you want so what are you
waiting for click the link in the
description and enter code gig out20 at
checkout for 20 off your first box or
you can just go to bespoke.com Gig up
20. thank you to bespoke posts for
sponsoring this video alright weebs back
to isakai I swear to God this isn't
Stockholm syndrome the video all right
there's no secret that isakai doesn't
really have the best reputation among
anime fans and I absolutely see why the
same Bland overpowered protagonist being
transported or reincarnated or summoned
to that same RPG world with the same
Harem living the same self-insert power
fantasy the using our genre definitely
went through an extended phase where we
got some [ __ ] like a lot of [ __ ]
like oh oh stinky poopy
I really still shouldn't find a spotting
sure there were outliers that stood out
but a lot of us got bored of the scene
very very very quickly and if you ever
wondered why it was ever like this then
you have one place to blame
this is a site where users can post
their own web novels for others to read
kinda like the YouTube of light novels
re-zero slime Therma spider Overlord
meshooka tensei Shield hirokonosuba if
there's an isakai big or small that's
come out in the last 10 years it's
probably come from here so when I'm
talking about modern isekai what I'm
really referring to is not okay or
stories that have come from this one
site and if you look at the stories that
have been adapted from here you'll
basically see how much it's had an
effect on the modern isekai culture if
you've ever wondered why a lot of modern
light level adaptations feel so [ __ ]
homogeneous isakai or not it's probably
because the source material originated
from here and if I'm allowed to put my
tinfall hat on for a moment and
speculate based on other sites with user
generated content all of this kind of
makes sense remember when Casey neistat
started posting and then every YouTuber
Vlog needed to be a Casey neistat Style
video oh and Mr Beast blew up and then
everyone to this day is still trying to
Market their videos like a cheap copy of
Mr Beast well imagine the same kind of
influence between creators being
permeated through an entire generation
of web novel authors on a single site
and suddenly you understand why a lot of
isekai and fantasy stories feel like
they are copying from each other why do
light novel titles sound so [ __ ] dumb
was because they are literally clickbait
to get users to click on their story
like you see with YouTube videos except
imagine if our YouTube videos get turned
into professionally published works and
you're stuck with titles like I got
addicted to YouTubers and regret
everything honestly that's not a bad
title for a light novel content creators
will naturally gravitate towards the
type of content they see doing well no
matter what platform they're on it's
something we see with any site YouTube
tiktok twitch does that excuse the
amount of mediocrity that's come from
there no but it does give a bit of an
insight into why so many isakai were
made and sets the stage for the state of
the genre today recently it really feels
like the isekai anime being adapted has
finally started to find its own footing
and and we're moving past the point
where shows were defined by a single
cheap gimmick well we're in another word
except this guy has a smartphone and
this guy is a mum and this guy is a
vibrator instead more often I think
we're seeing actual interesting Concepts
they get explored in more depth like
people are starting to realize that
audiences want more than just the same
power fantasy show with some dumb [ __ ]
gimmick slime season 2 took his premise
and then fully leaned to becoming a
civilization type City Builder where
rimaru actually encounters problems he
can't just solve with Force makes hard
decisions makes mistakes and then fully
suffers the consequence of it the
world's finest assassin said let's
isakai John Wick if you take someone
who's already skilled and Powerful in
the real world how would he use his
skills and knowledge to break the
systems presented in the fantasy world
what happens when a goddess isakai is
more than one person to get the job done
what will the majority of people do
realist hero takes a really interesting
look at what happens if we take modern
psychology and apply it to governing a
medieval fantasy setting
machiavellianism Game Theory eventually
in the manga gets to the point where
we're using examples from the Cold War
capitalism fighting communist ISM the
main character takes lessons we've
learned from our own history and applies
what has historically worked for us in
another world these are just some of the
interesting ideas I came across with the
shows this year and many of them aside
from the basic premise and setting
explored totally different subjects and
ideas like now just because you see
several isekai airing in a single season
that's no indicator that the shows will
actually have anything in common with
each other mishokotensei re-zero my next
life is a villain s a sentence of a
bookworm restaurant in another world
these are all isekai set in your
traditional fantasy world that are
completely independent of each other in
plot tone characters and appeal I've
been killing slimes for 300 years has
more in common with dragon maid than it
does with the other isekai with slime in
the title is there still a lot of
garbage being made yes but it's no
longer as relevant to look at a new show
and say it's not like your typical
isakai because a lot of isekai are no
longer like your typical isekai I don't
know if this is sounding like massive
isekopium right now so I just want to go
in a little tangent to look at what I
think might be a similar case that
happened for gaming
I remember when these first exploded
onto the scene and you couldn't get away
from them halo revolutionized console
Shooters setting the blueprint that many
modern Shooters still use to this day
Halo 2 set the stage for online gaming
only for Call of Duty 4 to Skyrocket
Shooters into the mainstream and from
there on there was no turning back your
friends started playing Shooters your
brothers and sisters and your cousins
started playing Shooters heck I think I
even caught a glimpse of your grandma
playing Search and Destroy on Terminal
once shooters were absolutely
inescapable and there was a point where
I swear every big game released was a
shooter or had some kind of [ __ ]
shooter mechanics in it shoot her after
shooter after shooter after shooter it
was like we were getting the same copy
and paste game from every big company
trying to cash in on a quick Buck
oversaturation was a real thing and
Gamers were getting visibly fatigued by
them all so 20 years later what do we
have to show for it
well Halo's got a grapple hook now as
tired as we got of Shooters they never
really went anywhere but instead carved
out its own Corner in the industry that
is still consistent to this day did we
get another Cod 4 or Halo Combat Evolved
no but what we did get was small tweaks
and innovations that slowly meant that
different Shooters could find their own
Niche you want something more on a grand
scale of battles with vehicles well go
play Battlefield want something more
team based and tactical well
Counter-Strike and Rainbow Six is a
thing colorful abilities how about
OverWatch Battle Royale 2 well good
thing Apex exists oh you just want to
see your childhood ruined well
there's still fortnite I don't know why
Itachi gets so much Flack from ordering
the yuccio clan where Sasuke right here
is quite clearly murdering their entire
Legacy the term shooter in the first
place is such a broad term for a game
where you point at something then click
a button for that object to commit die
and I think this could be what isikai is
turning into for anime yusakai could
just become a staple of anime the same
way that high school is there are
hundreds if not thousands of anime shows
set in high school but that doesn't mean
that any two shows are gonna have
anything in common with each other if
anything I just wish these shows put in
a little bit more effort to at least
look more distinct you look at some
genres in anime and you're like damn all
of these have such distinct style and
feelings of them and then you look at
this car and you're like
they're the same picture it's like every
show he's still using the same two
character designers with the same
[ __ ] color palette that just melds
into one conglomeration of generic mess
that makes it impossible to discern any
of these shows at just a glance but you
know what baby steps at this point isaka
is just comfort food for me sometimes it
is still the same copy and paste show
yes there is still a lot of trash out
there but more often now you'll find
these neat little ideas packaged into
the same familiar formula you've seen
that will make you take a step back and
think huh
that was actually pretty damn fun I'm
not saying Easter guys suddenly turned
over a new Leaf but what I'm saying is
in 2021 it didn't feel as cheap anymore
and there was more variety than ever for
a genre that is apparently all the same
I do think it still has one massive
problem but it's just not the one
everyone seems to complain about because
to me the one biggest thing I wished
would change is that
there needs to be an Easter guy that has
an ending in almost a decade of the
genre I don't think I've seen a single
one come to a conclusion and it's kind
of getting to me pretty much the only
ones I could think of are shows that
came before the modern boom all of them
even the so-called good ones don't feel
like they've gotten anywhere close to
being finished No Game No Life more like
no season two no more Overlord yeah
Overlord of half a [ __ ] Kingdom
rising of The Shield hero yeah this is
more like the slight incline of The
Shield hero re-zero more like zero
chance of ever seeing this end okay that
was awful my problem with modernizikai
isn't that they are bad is that they're
so damn disposable we start with one
easy guy have a bit of fun and then just
move on to the next one and then forget
about all of them it feels like a lot of
the times Writers come in with a single
interesting idea explore it and then
have no idea where to go so the readers
lose interest or the writer just stops
I've seen so many Heroes journeying to
take on a Demon Lord and not a single
one has ever reached his doorstep that
doesn't feel like there's anything close
to a complete story and instead of focus
thing on finishing one it feels like the
focus for anime is making six more and
because of this nothing has any staying
power we don't see any stories reach
their maturity and because of this it
becomes so vapid Michelle kutensei
re-zero Overlord it's series like these
where you can see the foundations being
laid for a full-blown tale there is
death there is characters there's a
thought Out World behind it it feels
like these shows are actually trying to
tell a full story rather than coming in
with a few interesting ideas than
[ __ ] off re zero just spent an entire
[ __ ] season in one place so they
could say hey let's have Subaru stop
dying so cheaply let's make Amelia an
actual character and while a lot of
people may have found the slower
progression boring I respect the fact
that I had the confidence to spend the
time to really flesh out sides of these
characters we never got to see in season
one and Michelle could tensei is well
you already know how I feel about
meshooka tenso if there was a show that
could lead the charge for all the
changes I wanted to see this could be it
because unlike most other isakai The
Source material is already done yes it
has a [ __ ] ending that's why I hope
to God that these types shows will get
the chance some funny follow through
with the story they want to tell like
your attack on titans my hero academias
and Demon slays they get the seasons all
the seasons they rightfully deserve
because I didn't feel like we're even
close to reaching the Peaks these
stories could tell and I think it's only
when we do get the chance to see some of
these Peaks that isakai can start being
taken more seriously I think this is the
one thing single-handedly stopping
isekar from eating at the big boys table
where we don't have to feel like
pointing at these shows we like and say
no guys this is a good show for an
isakai and instead just saying no guys
this is just a good show in conclusion
isakai will never die
it just gets reincarnated into knowledge